scream is one tapping and valorant these
days but just how successful was his CS
go career he's got one bullet in it he's
three let's go one bullet oh
scream went pro and Counter-Strike
Source when he was just 16 years old he
quickly joins up with future French
Legend shocks and together they made
history the two played on iconic CS go
teams like very games Titan and Epsilon
scream at one and two
Spire us a triple kill it's a quick kill
foot scream over the years scream did
win some silverware including the ECS
season 1 finals but his rosters never
found consistent success thanks in part
to infighting and well plain old bad
luck but of course scream didn't need
accolades to become a star nope he
became famous because no one else in the
world could one tap quite like him they
talk about my one Taps it's their g-side
where they really struggle
oh
scream so yeah scream never won a major
or a grand slam but he still has the
highest headshot percentage in CS go
history and well that speaks for itself